oft kommen sie von schulen an denen es
anders zugeht und hier war eingehen oder
weil es okay aber jetzt ist es schon so
dass ich wirklich jahre warum muss man
jetzt und ich möchte auch keine schuhe
für sorgen dass unser auge hat aber so
angst um sein leben
wenn wir mal in unserem leben einer
schule waren oder jetzt kann er noch an
einer schule sind dann kennen wir alle
lehrer die ziemlich schmutzig sind wir
keine alle lehrer die ziemlich nice sind
aber leute aber die schuldirektoren sind
öfters die schlimmsten aber meine
schuldirektoren und eure müssen sich
jetzt hinten anstellen denn ich habe ein
video über den strengsten schulleiter
deutschlands gefunden und das schauen
wir uns jetzt an
um halb acht schließt der schultour und
wer zu spät kommt haus putzen
hart traf deutschlands wohl strengster
schulleiter michael rudolph durch was
war das für sie wird zu spät kommt muss
putzen so einerseits ok checke ich das
soll eine strafe sein
aber was ist die logik dahinter also man
will ja als schule denn ich dass die
leute zu spät kommt warum nicht damit
sie keinen unterricht verpassen die
logik da drin ist dann natürlich okay
was haben wir hier misst wir haben einen
schüler der drei minuten zu spät ist hat
drei minuten drei wertvolle minuten vom
unterricht verpasst was machen wir
deswegen wir schicken ihnen prozent
damit er noch 42 weitere minuten
wertvollen unterricht verpasst
wenn schüler an dieser einfachen regeln
gewöhnen und sich daran halten dann
werden sie sich auch an die ernstlichen
regeln halten also zum beispiel keinen
zu schlagen oder keine zu verletzen
der gut okay okay man muss auch dazu
sagen schuldirektor ist auch kein
leichter job ja ich will ja in meinen
videos auch immer eine sehr ausgewogene
sicht der dinge darstellen die man
sprechen muss man auch sagen es ist
nicht leicht eine schule zu führen
deswegen auch wirklich viel viel respekt
an alle schulleiter in deutschland die
will ich überhaupt nicht angreifen und
auch an alle lehrer
denn sind wir ganz ehrlich leute es ist
nicht leicht und es war nicht leicht
gewesen es mit uns auszuhalten schlimme
zustände herrschten auch an der
friedrich bergius schule
friedenau als michael rudolph 2005 die
leitung übernimmt
ganz ehrlich man weiß bei ihnen schon
sofort dass er das selbst raiders es
gibt so schulleiter und das muss ich an
der stelle aussagen also als ich noch in
der schule war auch ein schulleiter der
war einfach ultra gechillt das war's
schon relativ alter ehemaliger lehrer
und er hatte einfach keinen bock mehr
sich mit dem ganzen stress
auseinanderzusetzen also wirklich zero
man hat ihn nie gesehen er hat gefühlt
auch keine präsenz gezeigt in der schule
das war wirklich so gefühlt weil es
einfach nur so ok als schulleiter kriege
ich jetzt mal ein bisschen mehr gehalt
so danach habe ich eine fette pension
wenn ich in rente gehe
lasst mich einfach in ruhe aber ich
glaube er ist damit nicht zu vergleichen
am dritten tag meiner anwesenheit war
tag der offenen tür oder diesem tag der
offenen tür fuhren aus allen vier
himmelsrichtungen autos mit so einem
blauen licht so einem blinkenden auf und
zu krass also kam die polizei zur schule
da sieht okay da sieht man wieder also
wie skat eben schon gesagt habe einfach
ist die ganze sache nicht gerade weil er
auch glaube ich an also so wie das ganze
im schneematsch eine problemschule
gekommen ist und da ist es noch mal um
so schwerer leute ich war an einem
reinen gymnasium da würde man vielleicht
ja erwarten keine ahnung ist vielleicht
meine meinung dass die leute da ein
bisschen mehr noch klarkommen als
vielleicht an einer hauptschule oder so
kann kann man das so sagen ich weiß
nicht ob es jetzt falsch ist aber selbst
an diesem gymnasium leute ging wirklich
die post ab und ich bin ehrlich ich will
da nicht spürt da sein wollen aber er
hat schauen wir noch kasseler schule
weil schüler der eigenen schule sich
hier blutig und treppen ausgeschlagen
spätestens klar es muss sich etwas
ändern
maßnahme nummer eins keine handys oder
kopfbedeckungen im schulgebäude
ok keine handys gab es für uns auch dass
das wahr was trades sobald du irgendwie
also du durftest gerade noch so sein
handy dabei haben macht ja auch keinen
sinn man muss ja vor der schule
vielleicht mit den eltern telefonieren
nach der schule dass er einen abholen so
durfte das sie gerade auch dabei haben
aber wehe wehe deiner armen seele wenn
das handy geklingelt hat im unterricht
so jäger
da machst du wirklich so am arsch dann
gnade wirklich gott aber so dass man
keine kappen tragen darf in der schule
wenn man durch den gang läuft studiert
wie kommt das bei den schülern ist
ärgerlich aber man muss sich daran
gewöhnen auf entzug vergisst man es
hätten 60 mal an traktion auf ich glaube
da muss heute ein jahr lang putzen
es hat ganz ehrlich an dieser schule
sind wir sehr strikt ja wir wollen nicht
dass schüler mit kopfbedeckung durch den
gang laufen weil wir alle wissen wenn
jemand eine kappe auf hat wenn er durch
den gang läuft dann ist er automatisch
drei noten schlechter in deutsch das ist
so maßnahme nummer zwei das schultor
öffnet und 725 und schließt schon fünf
minuten später wieder mit
unterrichtsbeginn wenn nicht rechtzeitig
kommt muss klingeln und sich als zu spät
kommer anmelden
okay das ist das ist crazy fünf minuten
einfach nur um in die schule rein zu
kommen das heißt letzten endes musst du
einfach du musst ja vor der schule
warten um rein gelassen zu werden
spieltag da habe ich ein bisschen
mitleid mit den leuten die an dieser
schule gehen ganz ehrlich gesagt habe
ich jeden auch ein bisschen ab manche
mehr manche weniger
aber jeder ein bisschen und dann ist es
wichtig so wenig nervt wie möglich dabei
zu haben und wenn du einfach morgens
schon vor der schule warten muss so als
wäre irgendwie neuer krasser jordan
gedroppt und du wartest vom sneakers tor
das schon in den unterricht geht es zur
nächsten stunde genau das alte minute zu
spät und dann greift die logik dann
greift die logik leute weil wir wollen
nicht wir wollen nicht dass schüler den
unterricht verpassen
deswegen wenn sie eine minute unterricht
verpasst hätten oder drei weil sie noch
durch die schule gehen müssen gehen wir
erstmal sicher dass sie auch noch 42
weitere minuten verpassen also
übertrieben natürlich ist das eine
strafe für die schüler bei keinem mensch
bock hat zu putzen so ist klar aber im
ernst ich glaube der hausmeister finden
das natürlich so hielt ein schüler
unentschuldigt werden direkt die eltern
verständigt schweizer haben keine chance
also eine militärische ein klarer regeln
soll den schülern respekt und disziplin
beibringen okay aber aber es ist auch
wichtig es ist wirklich wichtig dass man
auch schülern disziplin beibringen
also das hier ist jetzt ein extremer
fall wie gesagt also das hat mit dem
putzen soll es halt schon relativ krasse
strafe natürlich gerne in die schule um
zu lernen wie man müll am besten aufhebt
oder werden fenster sauber hält oder
nicht will am ende hatte zumindest ein
bisschen können oder englisch aber ich
glaube auch viele schüler kriegen
einfach zu hause das so nicht mit wie
sie wie man sich halt wie diszipliniert
verhält wie man sich an die regeln hält
weil viele eltern einfach nicht
konsequent sind und ich glaube ich muss
ehrlich sagen wenn man in dieser schule
ist während man in der schule ist ist es
die hölle aber danach hat man schon was
gelernt das leben würde ich sagen oft
kommen sie von schulen angenehm ist
anders zugeht demontierbar eingehen oder
weil das okay aber jetzt ist es schon so
dass ich wirklich will aber in warum
muss man wir machen jetzt und ich möchte
auch gerne schuhe für sonstige weil
seine auge hat aber so angst um sein
leben wahrscheinlich jetzt oder direkt
dahinter der kamera und hat schon so er
macht schon so seinen gürtel auf und ist
schon so jung gesagt eine falsche sache
denke ich mach dich fertig man sieht
richtig also bloß nichts falsches sagen
bloß nichts falsches sagen ich will ich
will ich will meiner mutter wieder sehen
ich will meinen vater wiedersehen meine
alten gefühlt die leute waren laut und
die lehrer hatten keine autorität von
meinen freunden von anderen schulen
würde ich immer antrag das ist eine
prügelei grab oder dass irgendjemand
sagt auf dem klo rate andauert ok de
gaia man kennt man kennt es leute eine
alltägliche begebenheiten deutschen
schulen die so zum schulalltag dazu
gehört wie das rechnen in mathe oder das
gedichte analysieren in deutsch aber
will sollte an seiner andere alten
schüler dass ich nicht wohlgefühlt fand
einfach nicht ständig an seiner alten
schule konnte man noch leben mann konnte
durch die schulgebäude gehen ohne angst
um sein leben zu haben das geht
überhaupt nicht
eine ganz klare struktur
ja das ist nämlich das ist genau das was
ist meine leute auch das ist wichtig
also ich mache ich natürlich meine witze
ich übertreibe
aber ich glaube man kann auch wenn das
krasse maßnahmen sind die sind sicher
und in ihrem ganzen umfang gut aber man
kann jungen leuten da wirklich sehr viel
mitgegeben gerade die wie es kann eben
schon mal die einfach von zu hause aus
keiner disziplin bekommt da kann das
auch wenn es im ersten moment krass
wirkt schon viel helfen das erstaunliche
auch die schüler sind überzeugt vom
harten kurs das schon gut aber jetzt da
ist weil die todesangst können wir sagen
okay was hat er direkt mal gesagt was
soll ich sagen es gibt nämlich auch
solche direktor muss man auch dazusagen
möglicherweise ist er ja auch so einer
die extrem darauf bedacht sind so eine
show abzuziehen ja die allen beweisen
wollen die frage ist wem weil wer schaut
zu außerdem direktor das ist die beste
schule ist dass es die sauberste schule
ist dass das keine ahnung was ist was
ich auf die bildungsminister in ihrem
land werden wollen oder irgendwas
maßnahmen in deutschland streng es der
schulleiter seit jahren deutschlandweit
für aufsehen sorgt was wartet heute ich
habe vorher schon mal die kommentare
gesagt ich habe einen krassen kommentar
gefunden das kommentiere ich auch einige
leute unter dem video die selbst an der
schule waren das ist das was sie sagen
hier zum beispiel also ich war von 2008
bis 2012 an dieser schule kennen den
rektor sehr gut und ich muss sagen so
wie er die schule immer darstellt so ist
es seit jahren nicht mehr circa 2010
ging es los das nur noch fernsehteam
star waren und fast gefühlt jeden morgen
schauen schauen wie diese soft boxen von
den kamerateams an und blendeten die ich
am frühen morgen zunächst wieder auf
einmal immer öfter der unterricht aus da
für den sender kicker eine kinderserie
auf dem schulgelände gedreht wurde
genau das was ich gerade in mind
zwischen anmeldezahlen für nach
gepackten vorzeigeschule mit rang vier
[Musik]
also muss sagen auch wenn es teilweise
wirklich krass ist was hier dargestellt
wurde wie gesagt ich respekt an den
schulleiter dafür
und wenn man eins sagen muss dann dass
dieser mensch hasselt jeden tag 4 uhr
ich glaub ich werde nicht nur leute in
meinem leben ich schreibe jetzt mal in
die kommentare
neuer schuhe das so drauf wissen was so
die krassesten sachen an eurer schule
sind die die schule von anderen schulen
abheben ganz liebe grüße an meine alte
schule des friedrich dessauer gymnasium
in aschaffenburg leute ich bin raus an
der stelle täglich vorschlages video auf
dem ein knall